Kaboom cup boom all right we're live
we're live baby
yay hot breath was happening
this is this is great this is gonna be
great
camera
whose camera is great
joles it is you know you know it's that
white privilege
that white don't crack you know
great on camera terrible in real life
but great
this is filter I got the white privilege
filter on
hilarious so funny
[Laughter]
well let's uh welcome everyone watching
live do this a lot where we are we
probably hang out a little too much
sometimes Joe and I are gonna be on a
show together this weekend
actually yeah this is Friday this Friday
yeah at a country club
at a country club just my kind of people
people with money let's go people let's
go like hunting dogs
[Laughter]
if you got an HOA and a 401k I'm the
comedian for you
yo that's a great opener that's a great
line
that's a keeper that's a keeper keep it
all right we in here let's uh let's
let's intro Our Guest we got John
Mondragon and Gwendolyn and Micah
watching on our YouTube
[Music]
Channel that's exciting oh the comments
aren't showing up over here you know
what it's all gravy
oh you can oh okay
I can see Gwendolyn I like that name
awesome Gwendolyn
oh I see now okay cool
all right well let's let's do an intro
and get Eva in here so welcome back
everyone to hot breath live our weekly
live stream where we answer your
questions
all about comedy I'm Joel Byers
I am Yoshi so in the building
and we've got a doozy today Yoshi she's
coming back on her first episode she was
just telling us she gets messages like
every week about her first episode uh
you produce shows I produce shows we
produce shows together so the two years
ago she came on here dropped a lot of
sauce but she's back and better than
ever more sauce most sauce Mo sauce we
giving the goodies we appreciate
everyone watching live on our YouTube
channel or listening to the podcast
later go subscribe to our YouTube
channel and be a part of these weekly
live streams
and without further Ado Yoshi you ready
let's go baby
for this one
welcome the one and only
Eva alexopoulos everyone Give It Up
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't have the sound effects so we
just do mouth effects
we got um how about this one
all right there we go we got some we got
some sound effects
here we go
Ava's face is just Emma's face is just
the best right now I just want to know
what his little sound looks like from
here
there we go
Eva welcome back oh yeah star of the
line is here Joan and Bob Kirk Bob
Kirk's up in Toronto
oh this is gonna be exciting so welcome
back guys thank you thanks for having me
back I miss you guys it's been a while
it has been a while I've been following
you from afar though I'm a fan of what
you've built and you're continuing to
build so I mean maybe for the people who
haven't heard your first episode maybe
give them just a brief a brief rundown
on what's goody in the hoodie of Eva and
uh we'll get into it here yeah for sure
so for some of you who don't know me my
name is Eva alexopoulos I'm a comedian
and a producer of Montreal's largest
English comedy party called the kickback
we've been going on for about three
years now it's a really nice community
and a really big comedy party and we've
been about we're going on to our 20th
sold out show in three years so I'm uh
I'm pretty shocked still and taken taken
back by the community that's been built
over the past three years but uh we're
based in Montreal and since then we've
seen the key Community grow even bigger
and more producers kind of come out of
that so if you guys are ever in Montreal
just hit us up and head on down and
we'll show you how cool the scene is
over here oh that is absolutely amazing
oh like I heard everything you said but
my ears and my mouth and my everything
just flared up when you said 20 sold out
shows
oh my goodness that is I mean here's the
thing I've been me and Joe have been
producing for a while now
like I've had like a couple of sold out
shows but 20 sold out shows that's
that's
hard that's going hard in the paint
right there
dude I'm telling you sometimes so I'm
not gonna lie and I think anyone who's a
producer can understand that is like
when it's happening and while you're
doing it you're like I can't believe we
did it and then the day after like wow I
did it but while it's happening up until
the very moment your the show's about to
start you're like yeah I hate myself and
why do I do this
who hurt me
but even after the show you're like oh
now I have to do it all over again
put it all together and Market it and
everything but it seems like you built
like you said like an entire Community
around the show now
yeah which is crazy so my um my partner
and I started the show three years ago
like right before covid you know it was
still an option to wear masks back then
and it was during the BLM movement and
he's a DJ and I'm a comedian and he kind
of sent me down on the couch and he was
like you know what if
what if we decided to throw like a
comedy show but like with an after party
and I'll DJ and you could host and I was
like I don't want to do that
I shut him down completely and he
continued to push it so it was 25 people
of like our our closest friends and
people we kind of knew here and there
and uh it ended up selling out 25 people
and then there was a shop bottle and I
was like you know in Greek culture we do
a lot of
salutes you know why don't we buy
everybody a shot and
That's How we'll start the show to just
get people a little more comfortable and
a and a little more amped up like what
what's the Worst That Could Happen
someone says no and it was that small
gesture that has kind of been such a big
part of the show strangely and it's not
even about really the alcohol we have
non-alcoholic shots as well but it's
just about breaking the ice within a
group of people who are really there for
the art for the comics and you're
creating a lot more of a supportive
environment whereas well the people
don't feel like they're going to get
ripped apart as audience members or
screamed at or belittled because it's a
supportive crew and the comedians know
they're there for them the comedians
know that you know those people in the
audience are really there to be their
biggest fans and uh and vice versa so
to know that we've attracted such nice
people to Comedy has kind of been the
craziest uh craziest thing to kind of
see grow over the past three years but I
I'm I'm
eternally grateful I still can't believe
it but we're both uh we're both really
proud of it
that's awesome I mean and they used a DJ
and comedy oh that's just the dream
right there
Yoshi DJs I've been trying to get him to
D we us do like a DJ comedy show thing
you know pretty cool you tried it one
time we tried it one time uh but I mean
I'm we might dig into this because I
really I am a fan of like mixing like
art forms together uh yeah I did a show
where I had a magician just so you guys
know never follow a magician in comedy
that's just rule number one you cannot
top a magician I had a headliner come he
was like why'd you have me go after the
magician I was like I didn't know that
it would be bad for you and I learned my
life it's one of those things
it wasn't even that he was funny it's
magic it's like another different level
well
well I guess that brings us to our first
point of the lesson is booking for your
audience
home she's a teacher
yeah we're gonna get into it yeah
because that's last last episode you
went into like branding creating an
experience for the audience creating
experience for the comedians as well
making sure it's something they want to
share and come back to and things like
that but even before the show you were
talking about all that you've learned so
since then when we did this two years
ago so yeah let's get into it here Eva
yeah so I feel like maybe we should go
back to the basics for some of our
friends who are kind of new here and
maybe we can do like a little recap to
kind of catch everyone up but
my background is also in marketing so a
lot of the things that we do with our
show are actually integrated with you
know corporate strategies social media
strategies I was a marketing expert for
a resort called Club Med for three years
that was all about Hospitality animation
and creating customer experience so a
lot of what the kickback is comes from
that and a lot of the stuff that you
guys are going to learn today are mixed
with hospitality marketing social media
management and Community Management
which is things that people don't always
think of in terms of Comedy but it's
super super essential to building a
successful show and people who who keep
coming back so the first thing that I
would ask anyone is when they want to
produce a comedy show is to ask yourself
these first three questions so
who am I producing this comedy for
what type of comedians do I think they
would like
how much money do I want to make off of
this how much do I want to pay my comics
and how am I going to do it and there's
a lot of different Avenues so for us our
who was
we are doing this for people who are not
necessarily already comedy fans but want
an experience
and who also love music and Montreal is
very comedy in music oriented so it was
how can we take the Montreal experience
and package it into not just a comedy
show but a comedy experience and how old
are those people and what you know what
do they do for a living and what kind of
things do they like do they like
throwback retro pop do they like EDM do
they like more art and animated stuff
and you can start building your brand
um off of that and then the biggest
question is why are you doing it so what
do you hope to achieve a lot of people
produce shows because it helps them
build their personal brand which is
always a great benefit it helps them get
stage time on other people's shows
because you know that's the politics of
Comedy you you give and you get and you
do all of those things
um but for us Roi was we want to build a
community of people who sustainably want
to continue coming to comedy shows and
feel like they're a part of something
and not just paying to to be thrown
people at them we wanted to create a
curated experience where our group knows
that whenever they come to a kickback
they're gonna get really great Comics a
great experience a free shot every time
and other little other little guests
from sponsors so those are really you
know big questions to ask so who am I
doing this for why am I doing it what am
I doing it for and then you can ask
yourself where and how
beautiful yeah Bobby said knowing your
why will make you try
Bobby knows best
cool
I like that
um as you build like as you first
started building the community did you
know exactly who all those people were
or was it the community that sort of
like developed that you then were like
oh this is who you actually kind of are
well I think for um for my partner and I
the way it started was truly with our
friends and it really took off with Word
of Mouth
so one of the benefits of Word of Mouth
marketing is that those people are
talking to like-minded people who are
talking to like-minded people and so on
so we knew we always had a great group
of friends
um Micah and I both grew up in the
church like he grew up with his family
on a traveling Christian band family
like ministers and so he's also grew up
in animation and getting people around
and I grew up really Christian as well I
went to Christian Camp and then so a lot
of animation and bringing people
together was kind of a basis so it's not
exactly a church but it's a Congregation
of some sorts because we still try to
attract a certain type of energy and a
certain type of person that believes in
kindness and support and exclusive
inclusivity you know it's really
important to us that when you walk in
you feel like we remember you we know
your name you're welcome here we
appreciate the fact that you spent 35 on
us because
the world is inflated right now so um I
think for us after maybe about 10 shows
we would start to look around and be
like
I don't know that person do you know
that person I don't know that person do
you know that person and it kind of you
know it starts to piggyback like that
because people bring friends of friends
and then again and then of course you
mix your actual social media marketing
and your branding and you target that
and you make sure to hit the right
people but
you know half the battle is just making
sure those first group of people have
the best time of their life and you make
sure that they feel seen because that's
what we do right the kickback is about
being seen whether you're an artist or
you're an audience member it's really
Our intention to make sure that you know
this is a place where you come to
diffuse from the world and kind of
forget that it's in Flames for just two
hours and you can go back to regular
programming
very cool that is yeah awesome yeah I
think thinking of the audience first is
something so interesting I mean I think
a lot of times I know the first show I
ever did I just wanted to do it for like
hosting experience and I was making 25
and then after doing it for four years I
was like oh I'm gonna ask for a raise
and then I started doing it for fifty
dollars
um you know so yeah 35
but like there's a difference between
like doing a show for free and maybe for
a tip jar and then selling like 35
dollars for a ticket to a comedy show
you know I mean at least here in America
I mean that's that's more than a lot of
comedy clubs charge so like there's a
lot that goes into like making sure
people get the value and the more than
they even expect with 35
yeah I mean it also has to do with you
know when you take into account like
your costs so lesson two costs are
really important and that's definitely
an area where we've made a ton of
mistakes and a ton of successes doing
um because again when you're producing a
show at first you're not really thinking
about profit and I think that is where
you find success in the long run because
our goal with this was never to make
money and there's some months we do and
there's Sun months we don't because we
want to put a little bit extra money
into investing to bring a comedian down
or we want to
invest in a bit of a better venue and in
the moment if you're kind of you know
self-centered like oh well I need to
make x amount and I need to make sure I
pay my rent with this and there was a
while where I was paying my rent with
the show and it was affecting my show
poorly because I couldn't make the the
type of like liberal decisions monetary
wise because I was focused on Surviving
so if you are producing a comedy show
especially at first do not do what I did
find another stream of Revenue so that
you can keep invest that money into your
show because again sometimes it's
necessary and you don't have a choice
and for a little bit I didn't and I'm so
grateful for everyone who was able to
like support us in that way
but having another you know revenue
streams that you can continue to invest
in your brand and in your product and
still be able to live the life that you
want is is truly truly important and
then finding the right you know website
domain and provider to work with so the
two I would recommend are universe
because they use a program called stripe
which is a kind of an online bank that's
really popular in the states and after a
while and after a certain amount of
shows you can actually send direct money
transfers to venues to your comedians in
advance and withdraw from your stripe
account so it's called stripe.com
universe.com that's what we use and that
way you're kind of able to send money
out so you're not waiting for that five
to ten day business period time to get
money in and you're kind of if you don't
have sponsors you're kind of scrunching
around trying to figure out how I'm
going to pay all these things and you
know pay all these people and get this
stuff done so I've made that mistake
before so definitely something to avoid
that's awesome that's that's some hidden
gems right there I like that oh yeah I
mean I you know Jonah I'm an open book
yeah do you do you have sponsors for
your shows now we do yeah so we have a
sponsor it's called Pro the prohibition
they're a wellness brand and we're also
in talks with uh paps and some other
liquor companies so because we give out
that free shot
and another you know another powerful
point for the show and why it's really
important to build community so when you
guys are looking for sponsors the first
thing that's really important is to
research for sponsors that actually
align with your brand and would be
interested and need something from what
you have to provide so for example
there's a lot of Brands who are looking
for people between the ages of 19 and 35
who are um nomadic workers and work in
marketing and they want those types of
people to start consuming their type of
vodka or tequila
so with us presenting me like well you
can have direct consumer to Brand
experience you can sponsor this event be
in charge of the signature shot and
Shout out and then they can give you a
certain amount of money or they can give
you for example some alcohol Brands will
give you five cases of beers for free
and then you can sell that and that's
how you make back your
um Your sponsorship
um interesting okay so it could be a
flat rate or they give you free product
that you can then sell at the actual
event yeah but what's important is
finding you know because you can
approach anyone like you can get
Pizza Hut or a bank to throw money at
you but while it's good yes I recommend
them more for like larger scale type of
shows
people especially now I I believe
especially since post covid with the
rise of tick tock and gen Z storytelling
is at its peak and people are really
looking for authenticity and people who
are honest and they're looking for a
connection
so sometimes whether it kind of looks
like oh great we got you know Bank of
America is a sponsor you're not going to
have that laid-back cool person who's
looking for a comedy show be like Bank
of America dope
[Laughter]
like let me let me go let me go to the
Bank of America let's go hit up that
comedy show I bet it's hilarious but
Chuck E cheese
[Music]
so it sounds it sounds silly and it
sounds super obvious but even for us
you know finding a sponsor isn't always
easy but when you do find sponsors that
actually feel like Partners which is
what we're kind of building now and
people who really believe in your brand
it takes you so much further so don't be
in a rush to just get anyone really look
for for sponsors that kind of align with
your values and what you stand for and
that way the people who align with that
are going to be more attracted to your
show and that's how you create that
starter sense of community
and you when you pitch these sponsors do
you have like a one sheet or something
that shows the alignment that you both
have
yeah so there's there's a few ways that
we've done it so we were really lucky
with our first sponsor they approached
us they came to a show so that's another
thing that you guys can do if you're not
really into the cold emailing thing
which is also
not truly my vibe
um something I've always done and I find
a little bit more you know inviting and
chill as always
um is one following those brands from my
account sending them a simple message
that I really appreciate what they do
and thanking them for doing it because I
mean it and I I let it go for a little
bit
but I don't even I don't even come off
hot I just I let it I let it go because
at least you're showing you're not
starving you're not hungry you're
confident in who you are you're
confident in your brand and you're
letting them know that you see them
and that way it creates a space for I
think we can benefit each other and I
think there's something that I could do
to help your brand because even as
someone who worked in marketing for a
long time and would get a lot of
proposals I always found it less
appealing when I would get a cold email
someone just being like I run this and
this is what we want from you and you
can get this from us and explode it at
this number and it's right off the bat
instead of it being an organic
conversation and that's something you
sometimes works sometimes doesn't but
like I said you're better off inviting a
brand to come see your show for free
and seeing what you do and actually
having them have a real experience
because in the long run you'll you'll
get a lot more out of it than just the
simple like hi my name is Eva and I do
this and this is how many followers you
can get and this is how many this you
can get and give me your money
both strategies can work I just find for
us and and what we're about so it's a
very personable brand so we try to have
something a little more like why don't
you guys come enjoy it we'll have a
conversation and we can see how we can
benefit each other because I know that
you guys are trying to
um trying to get this type of
demographic and I know that that's our
demographic and it might be a little bit
more difficult so that's uh that's
that's our approach and I also made a
deck if you guys want to see it actually
it was made by our core producer Arianne
who's amazing
yeah you want to jump into the deck
you're saying yeah I want to show
everyone so this is this is something
that
um has been really helpful for us and is
really important so this was made by our
co-producer Arianne she did a great job
but I just wanted to show everyone what
um an about us pitch deck kind of looks
like because it also gives you a lot
more validity if you decide to send a
cold email if you're following up on a
conversation you have this ready for you
off to go and all the information that
they need to know even over a website or
just an Instagram because it goes above
and beyond but it's super effective
let's see if that works can they see
that oh yeah
I have it on the screen I pulled it up
on the screen
um can you see it on this the screen
yeah on
um on uh the live stream
this is the first time we're doing this
so I I pulled it up on my end okay so
I'm not share screening anymore am I
um yeah we couldn't figure out how to
get it to work
okay so this is you can you scroll up
and down and show me if it works yeah so
like this okay can you see that
yay awesome should we should we start at
the top and people listening to the
podcast go watch it on uh YouTube so you
can see it
well we can always I can always make a
scaled down version and send it to you
for the for the hot breath of verse like
the last time yeah you had it you had a
checklist for the last uh podcast we did
so yeah yeah well I'll send it again
we're able to see it on the live it's on
the live amazing so this is this is our
about us deck so this is what I send to
um anyone who's looking for like a press
release or to know a little bit about
our show when we're doing a press
release when we're sending stuff out to
sponsors so you'll also see our
sponsorship packages at the bottom
um to give you guys kind of an idea of
what you can put in a sponsorship
sponsorship package and what you can
include in it but there's different
scale rates and you know you can play
with that as you please but we have this
so we have our header which is our show
and then we explain what it is
and what our story is and then as you
scroll down you can see some of the
stuff that we've won and then we outline
the format where it explains what the
show's about what the length is how it
goes about where we are at this tart
spot in our career
where you can have seen some of our
comics and our show and just sometimes
you know set the vibe set the tone yeah
it's really important so when you're
approaching sponsors and let's say for
example they're looking for
um more Roi so return on investment they
want to see more followers from their
page and they want to know what your
statistics are and how many people you
reach and they also want to know their
age groups how many are men women
non-binary do you have an email list
which is also something that's really
attractive to them because that's
something that you could add into your
packages our email blasts for example so
all the times that you sell on your um
on your platform or on your website and
you collect those emails what we do is
that the day after the show for example
I send an email class thanking everybody
who came to that kickback
a discount code and the link to the next
show for pre-sale tickets
oh that's the way to keep things kind of
fresh but it also is is genuine and it
doesn't end up in their junk box because
it's coming from the event website that
they bought the tickets for yeah and
they know it's used so it doesn't come
off spammy it's like guys thank you so
much for coming here's a here's a
discount code here's a pre-sale link for
cheap tickets like just showing that
you're a person and not just this
machine that is constantly demanding
people of uh of their money so
that's kind of how we like to do it
yeah so like as I'm listening to you you
uh like there is so much customer like
experience and like Fan Experience in
the way that you think about comedy and
the way that you're thinking about like
the entire like experience and obviously
you mentioned that you've got a
marketing background and what I want to
know is like
how did you get to that point to apply
those kinds of things to Comedy because
that's not really applied to a lot of
Comedy I mean I haven't seen a lot of
comedy shows I don't remember the last
time I gotta thank you for going to a
comedy show or going to an open mic or
something like that so like I'm
wondering like how did you get to that
point and what are the things that you
think producers and people that want to
start comedy shows can think about to
get to that place where they're thinking
the experience
yeah well I'm I mean I I would I'd have
to be honest and say it kind of goes
back to my roots right
um Greeks are big hosts
the every woman needs to have their turn
hosting Easter and making sure that
everyone has the most food and you know
the most guilt trips
amazing
um food and guilt trips oh my God
because you're not cleaning you're not
this you're not that
um but there's a lot of there's a lot of
there's a lot of um
giving in our culture it's a lot about
giving out giving out strangely it's a
lot of martyring too but you could find
the positives with it I still struggle
with it but it's like no no you eat I
won't eat oh here eat more eat more like
there's definitely a basis of where that
comes from and then again you know kind
of growing up in the church and you know
going to youth group and having that
Community as well and making sure that
people felt as accepted as possible
which was my experience in the church
anyways I know that not everyone has
that but I always felt really you know
welcomed and like I kept those values
and my partner keeps those values as
well of you know at the end of the day
it's just about making sure people feel
accepted no matter what
and giving that Grace and making sure
that despite who they are you're looking
at them and you see the person that they
are
um and then the biggest part is
definitely as well working for Club Med
which was a French Resort I lived out in
the Caribbean for three years and the
biggest part of that company was
customer engagement so we would have to
eat with the guests party with the
guests
um not sleep with the guests but
everything else
your partner's creeping over the camera
right now excuse me because I was not
that type of Club Med girl but
that that customer experience I was a
go-go girl I'd have to do all of the the
dances when the shows would start you
know I was I was standing on bars in the
costumes you know getting all the guests
all riled up and and ready to go and it
was embedded in us for three years you
know we had to stand outside of the
restaurant and greet every person by
name and being in that environment for
three years and seeing how people really
felt seen when you remembered them and
at the end of the week they would cry
saying bye to you which is not a normal
Resort reaction that most people have
anyways but that's what made Club Med
such a popular successful Resort
training they were the inventors of all
inclusive so that was my training
environment for three years it was it's
12 o'clock and it's the it's the foam
party and we need our dancers to go up
so I was one of the dancers and I'm just
googly googly and then we have to do the
clap clap for the circus show where we
all stand in a line and we clap for all
the guests coming through so so
it was really instilled and embedded in
us that you better make sure you
remember every name every person when
you see them you make sure they feel
like the king and queens of the world
and I'm glad that I took that from that
experience and brought it to the show
because it really is a Formula that
works and it's so easy to be kind and
welcoming so much more than it is to be
cold and bitter to people and it's such
an overlooked thing to just smile at
someone and say I remember you like
you'd be shocked how many people come in
like you remember me from last show
really you remember me of course I'm
staring at the entire audience all the
time and it it's something so small that
goes so far and I can't ignore is a
reason why you know people keep coming
back is that person ability and maybe
it's a little more socially exhausting
but to make someone feel special is like
is the best way to keep a loyal customer
right even when you go to a Shopper's
Drug Mart and you have like 25 thousand
points you can get yourself like a
free cheese I don't know what example
I'm using but when you get you know when
you get rewards from from like a club
that you're a part of or something like
that it always feels nice and it kind of
always feels worth it
um and so seeing that integrated into
the show of always standing at the door
so I always stand at the door and I
shake everyone's hand and I say nice to
meet you my name is Eva thank you so
much for coming to the show and we have
a little goodie table from our sponsors
with like little gifts that we give out
and we're like this is for you guys you
can take as much as you want it's our
way of saying thank you so Greek
weddings for example that's a very big
custom in our culture is that you leave
an event and you always have a goodie
bag
sometimes the grandmothers steal the
flowers and the plants but whatever we
don't have any of those so we just have
little little goodie bags and it's so
small but it goes so so so so far it's
definitely recommend doing a goodie
table with like candies fruit roll-ups
little Post-it cards with cute letters
and it makes people feel like they're
part of something secret and they're
part of something special think like
imagine going to Montreal and you end up
in a random Loft with cool lights and
projectors and it's behind a hidden door
like everyone dreams of that Scott
Pilgrim experience right and then you
get it and you're like oh this is not
just a show this is a community and I'm
gonna make a friend and then I'm gonna
meet that friend next month hi Oz
oh yeah I said hey Eva very cool
was there anything else from that
um
uh this uh presentation that you were
wanting to show
um if you guys want to see what
sponsorship packages look like
you can keep going down so here we just
have some testimonials of people that
wrote to us after a show those are
always nice for the words it gives
people a kind of an idea of how you know
your audience actually feels
and then you have who we are as the
producers with our little bio
so were there are there three people
behind kickback is it basically like
three people that kind of make
everything happen
yeah so it's it's myself it's my partner
Micah so he's actually the original
idea idea maker and creator of the show
he definitely pushed me to do it because
there was a moment I did not want to and
then my friend Ariane Tonka who is
amazing she's also from Montreal she
she's a Powerhouse of a woman Micah is a
Powerhouse of a DJ and a co-producer
he's he's DJ'd everywhere and anywhere
and he because of all of his travels he
really knows how to set a tone and set a
mood for people to enjoy music is such a
big part of a production and of a show
you have the right music you can get
people into any mood so his you know his
specialty is house and disco with a
little bit of hip-hop and that really
Montreal feel he he captured he captures
it so perfectly and I'm I'm so grateful
for that because I don't even think the
show would be that without him and his
his taste right so everyone has their
little puzzle piece and their magnet to
make make it what it is and Ariane kind
of also took what we had and magnified
it because she used to have a marketing
company as well so she has that
marketing background but she helps
produce the low-key Comedy Show Out Of
The Comedy Store in LA with Matt Rife
and Paul yeah I'm from another show yeah
yeah we met because she came to my show
and then I started you know Consulting
her on ways that she could help with
like low-key comedies social and growing
that and she's uh she's been such an
expander in the show and you know she
made she designed this whole about his
kit and helped us get off the ground and
she's a wonderful photographer and
videographer so creating a team as as
you grow is really important because for
a while we were kind of solo and I was
definitely drowning and I was definitely
last minute with a lot of things and
sometimes people would think that the
kickback was just this thing that was
announced a week before but really I was
so busy I forgot yeah I didn't even know
it all worked out like it wasn't it
wasn't always that like everybody makes
mistakes and sometimes life gets super
busy but when you do have a good team
and you do have a good support system
even the day of the show to take some
stuff off of your shoulders it it just
it only really helps you expose so if
you guys are producing shows together
it's a good thing
yeah it makes it more fun and more
sustainable because I I've done it both
ways and you can very easily get burnt
out or it can very easily suck the fun
out of the show if it's you doing
literally everything so yeah so it's
it's yeah it's good context of like yeah
you're producing this awesome show that
ended up being a part of JFL and there's
this amazing team behind it that makes
sure everything is running on all
cylinders so that that's definitely an
important note for comics and I I don't
have my other girls in here with me but
I have my on-site girls that hand out
the shots and help me set up all of the
venue let me get there and they're our
best friends and they also are like
having a good team like during the show
staff is also really important for the
comedy experience because crappy staff
can really ruin things for people a bad
waiter a bad bartender a bad greeter can
can really dim an experience off the bat
where it doesn't need to be but if you
truly find people who are an extension
of who you you are and can kind of carry
that Vibe you're you're set for life I
would be nothing without those girls
they always make sure no one takes the
shot before the show starts to the point
where like Tess is Italian so she'll
she'll spank people
it's it's one of those but uh but yeah I
guess we can keep going and just finish
that up oh yeah to see the sponsors oh
okay cool yeah we're getting into the
money yes so this is
what's really important maybe you can
zoom in
um when you're building a sponsorship
package or a proposal for a company
what's really important is showing them
where these costs are going and where
you're getting these numbers from so the
kickback is a high cost show so our
venues cost a lot we hire staff it's not
you know there's different ways to do
comedy shows you could easily find a
great bar who will give you uh the venue
for free as long as they take bar sales
and they'll even give you a you know a
budget for the comics to help pay them
just for bringing people in you can also
have that deal and have a percentage of
the bar or if you want to go completely
independent which is what we do this is
kind of you know what goes into building
up those prices and why it makes sense
then also giving people kind of an aloe
cart option and as well knowing what
your read should end and what um what
your influence is to kind of you know
kind of affects these things so if they
want to be a sole sponsor it costs a
certain amount if they want a shout out
of their name or a banner it costs a
certain amount when you think of
promotional videos and AD spend that
costs a certain amount and it still
gives them a lot of exposure because the
reason brands are going this way now is
because it's like a digital modern day
billboard
it's about Impressions so the more
you're giving don't devalue the power of
social media because reach can go very
very far and you guys are still kind of
helping each other
so for example for a promotional video
we have to hire a videographer we have
to get the videographer to edit
sometimes that takes six hours so that's
the cost of that if you want video
rights for example
um
so there's promo codes there's Flyers so
make sure to really always outline your
costs so I have digital flyers I have to
make that cost me 250 dollars I have a
videographer that cost me 500 so if you
want any part of that this is where this
number comes from and where it's going
and as long as it makes sense sorry yeah
so for like digital promotional video
are you shooting a promo for the sponsor
no it's if they so if they want their
logo included in let's put their logo on
it okay yeah to put their logo on it
yeah and then you know there's logo or
sometimes what you can offer companies
as a collaborative post where it'll show
up on their timeline and your timeline
or you can offer contest giveaway with
you know with their branding kind of all
over your page or in during the event if
they want their banner up in the back or
positioned in certain places those are
all factors you can consider when when
speaking to a brand so say they want
their Banner right on stage next to you
well that's going to cost a certain
amount rather than having it up against
a wall somewhere else right yeah
and and when uh do you do in
show promotion as well like yes so
there's certain companies for example
yeah so there's certain companies for
example who
um operate within the gray area of the
law so sometimes you'll have a cannabis
sponsor approach you and say you know
within these rights we're not able to
um to promote in Quebec or promote in
Ontario but we would like to sponsor
just our name we'd like to sponsor the
second signature shot under our name
during the event and then or there's a
QR code that they can follow and get a
t-shirt from that brand because they're
not specifically necessarily allowed to
do certain types of advertising so
there's so many different ways that you
can go about it but what's really
important when you're approaching
companies is to know your costs and
what's attributing into it so that it
all makes sense because sometimes these
companies will look and just kind of say
where are you getting two thousand
dollars from why would I
why would I do that and then once you
show it to them and you break it down
they're like okay they're not just
looking for they're not just looking for
money they're showing us the value so
then the number doesn't look so scary
and it doesn't really look like you're
chasing out for anybody or doing
something that you're not supposed to do
or cutting Corners because it goes both
ways right you know these companies also
don't want to feel like people are just
hunting for their money in their budget
during Q4 or Q3 and stuff like that
you should come off professional
yeah and and they they do get a lot out
of it right so for this specific package
you can get you can sponsor the official
cocktail hour so your logos and your
names are on everything and then we get
on stage and we give a shout out and we
thank you or we put up the QR code to
have people follow to really make sure
that both partners are getting are
getting exactly what they need
I'm a nerd out real quick as you started
talking about quarters uh
q4s is do you have a strategy like
around when you hit up these sponsors or
when you hit up certain people or like
no are there okay so uh but you should
but you should that's the thing it's
like you should okay I I didn't I didn't
always but for example
you need to give companies at least a
month
to send them a proposal so you can't you
can't just send a company be like hey my
Show's next week can you sponsor me off
the bat sometimes you'll be surprised I
Won't Say Never Say Never because I'm
the queen of things happening last
minute but for the most part a month to
two months in advance to show people
that you are prepared and you're ready
and this is what you have projected and
the other thing that will really help
you with sponsorships that brands are
looking for is consistency
that is something that is people don't
really talk about and that is often
missed but it's harder to get a one-off
sponsorship than it is to build a
partnership so if you have six shows you
know lined up
you should present that to them so that
we are a consistent show we do this
every single month without skipping a
month we've done x amount of shows
already and this is what we have
projected for us within the next six
months it's something that they can come
back to their team and look at and be
like okay how much can we allocate to
this budget or even give them the option
of what show they'd want to sponsor so
we have you know one show on 420 that we
had a wellness brand
approach us and say you know we'd like
to fully sponsor this and give out
t-shirts and give out this and give out
that but that's a two month in advance
and because it aligned with what their
mission was but they weren't sponsoring
the past two so giving people kind of
that that option and that conversation
to see where they can fit in or if they
want to be a premier sponsor and just to
know that you know this isn't just
something they're throwing their money
at because they have to see some Roi as
well a lot of these brands are looking
to Target a new audience they're looking
to gain more social media followers
they're looking to attract a certain
type of person that you might be able to
provide them but everyone knows you
don't just get them once right you don't
just start dating a guy after one date
they gotta Court you a couple more times
you need some consistency you gotta keep
watering that plan
can't get no hoochie without some some
nice pasta
wow that's been dating yeah yeah yeah
you know like your love like carbs yeah
that really once a month baby I'll take
you out
oh Olive Garden are you are you hosting
the show too like as far as a producer
are you hosting the show so you're doing
all the sponsorship stuff like up top so
do you have any advice for kind of like
producer slash host of what they should
do at the host part as to sort of
elevate the experience as well
yes
fun
uh I'll say it louder for the people in
the back come up to good music
one make sure
in the venue are dimmed
there's nothing every comics and
audiences like there's nothing worse
than being in a really highly lit room
having to see everyone's faces
it's super exposing it's super
uncomfortable uh do not recommend at all
dim warm so you get your yellows your
purples and your blacks and your Blues
those are really really important colors
for environment even on a site like a
psychological basis it calms people down
it Mellows them out so we have a color
scheme you'll see purple all over our
page
and purple will bring you back to purple
and yellow the 80s hip-hop laid back
there's a there's a cognitive message
that is kind of sent to your brain when
you walk in you're like oh I'm gonna
relax now and sometimes you know when
you have those like hardcore pot lights
just kind of shining down I will not
book a venue anywhere with spotlights
it'll never happen there's no way
no pots for me I will put Christmas
lights everywhere I can it'll look like
Christmas at the crumps house in that
place before I use spotlights
who look like a hipster from by Portland
I don't know
uh
all our Portland uh hot breathers are
like stop it yeah we are trendy
but yeah this is great yeah
but it's really important like your
Venue is your Venue is everything then
if you find a good if you find a good
venue you'll be able to
take a lot of the pressure off of
yourself and sometimes it's worth a bit
of the extra money because
you know if you find a venue that's Plug
and Play which means they have audio
recording systems set ready to go they
have their lighting already they have a
sound tech available
it takes a lot off of you worrying if
you're going to get feedback off of the
mic which we've done it's happened to us
with venues that are well established
and not well established so a sound
check super important making sure you
have dim lights candles are awesome
You Love candles set in that mood all
day long candles everywhere we even put
we even put incense
we even put incense I am crazy you will
smell nice you will feel nice
your party looks over the computer again
come on Club Med in and out crazy we're
like what kind of Comedy no
but you know smell is really important
we we once had you know we once had one
Kickback where we rented this venue
because we got double booked and there
was a bit of a funky smell and uh the
girl the girl came up to us and she was
like yeah it's an Old Montreal building
there might be a rat up there somewhere
dead but we got you some Febreze and
some incense and I was like oh bruh so
there it was
it almost looked like a seance in there
or a smoke machine there was so much
incense going everyone's like what's
that smell I was like nothing
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
I would say one of the most important
things like I said is is greeting it
takes a lot of the pressure off of you
because the second you introduce
yourself to someone especially as
they're walking in the door so as a host
like I said
stand at the door and greet everyone who
comes in and introduce yourself say
thank you for coming my name is X I
produce this show please take a seat
wherever you want we're gonna get
started in 10 minutes if you need
anything let me know
um I've had you know pregnant people
come to the show and I know to make sure
that they have lower chairs and they're
closer to the bathroom and that
attention to detail as a producer and as
a host is to kind of have that you know
that tuneage in your brain to be like
okay this type of person is coming where
can I actually seat them if I know I
have you know a group of ten and like I
said we give out a free shot
it's worked super well for us over the
years we've integrated having
non-alcoholic shots because we've
noticed again we have a lot of Muslims
who come to our shows or there are a lot
of people who just don't drink and they
choose not to drink and don't want to be
left out so
having that attention to detail to know
that this is really just a symbol for
togetherness and you don't have to
solely focus on you know getting messed
up which is what it fully used to be
especially during the pandemic you're
all like let's get drunk who cares let's
party like let's just Rebel and have fun
we're now it's people don't get like
we've we've had some people when we were
doing BYOB get did not know how to
handle their liquor and a lot of that
was also based on geography so I would
say for producers and hosts where you
choose
and the people that are around that area
you choose to produce a show will affect
the type of people you bring out because
the second that we just moved our venue
10 minutes away where our age group was
a little bit older in their late 20s
well I didn't have 19 year olds hugging
a toilet because they had too many pink
Whitney's on the floor and I only got
one bathroom in that old venue I'm
telling you we've learned a lot
but it's it's who do you really want to
attract do you want to track the goons
or do you want to track people who want
to like let loose and have a good time I
I love it yeah this was this was perfect
because your first interview it went in
a lot of like The Branding and the
marketing and all of that and this is
more on this is a lot of like the
business side of it which is great yeah
so yeah
yeah well yeah so between now the last
time we talked in this time is there any
other are there any other lessons you've
had to learn the hard way that maybe
other people won't have to oh wait wait
let me get started
one of the first
um one of the first things I learned
as a producer which I I don't make that
mistake anymore and I make sure to brief
it
when you have Comics coming from out of
town
I definitely believe that it is your
duty as a host as much as it is your
duty as a comic to do your research on
the area that you are planning to talk
about because I've had I've had comments
come on who I love dearly and I've seen
perform fantastic in their respective
cities and even cities outside of Quebec
but they'll assume that people from
Quebec
know their Burrows or no culturally
relevant terms so what I do now is you
know right before the show I say this
borough is the equivalent of this
Borough and one thing that montrealers
really hate is the haki making fun of
the accent we know we know where the
hillbillies of Canada we know we sound
weird when someone from outside comes
and tries to do the accent we're just
like
it's but it's a brief that I give for
their own benefits I'm like it's been
what done once it's been done twice it's
been done eight times try to steer away
from that they really just want to know
who you are so it's just as important to
brief the comics and make them feel you
know
as comfortable as possible to know who
they're talking to so they can have the
best chance at the best set possible and
and kind of prep them so I do that now
but I've made the mistake of not doing
that and one of the mistakes I've
actually made before is booking tick
talkers to do their first stand-up set
because that is not always transferable
that's one thing that's one thing I
learned clout does not always Trump
talent and I've booked Comics that have
done 10 shows and have destroyed a crowd
and I have booked comics with a hundred
thousand followers and all these
influence and got on stage and
completely froze it and I love them and
I think they're hilarious and I laugh at
every single video I've ever posted but
sometimes things are transferable and
sometimes they're not so I've made the
mistake before on booking based on you
know this is going to look really great
and they're really funny and I saw eight
videos and I bet they're hilarious on
stage and then you realize you've been
doing this for six years and public
speaking is a whole different game and
some people are great at it but
sometimes you know making that
transition
those those artists and those creators
are also learning something new just as
a comic would be learning how to use
tick tock on the reverse and they're not
as experts at all so it really comes
back to there have been a few times I
didn't book for my crowd and I booked
because I thought it was cool and I
thought it was good and I I thought it
would really work out when really maybe
they were improv and they should have
done sketch or really they were
um you know singers or maybe I could
have done a song during intermission but
you learn right and you have to make
sure to always show compassion
um as well for that type of stuff but oh
and booking too many comics
um
what amen so for you so real quick I'm
gonna get Logistics
how long is your show what do you think
sort of that right number of comics
is and do you have like a magic not a
formula but like do you what's like the
ideal
comedy sort of lineup for you in terms
of how many Comics how many minutes they
do you mean headliner that whole kind of
thing
yeah so for us what I've realized is
my audience because it's a comedy party
right and so the whole thing is very
high energy and even we have an
intermission as well because Montreal
what do we have
Smoke House everyone smokes like it was
just left right French cigarette like
that's what it's just it's part of the
Quebec culture it's what they need to do
so we have an intermission to kind of
give people a break but
I wouldn't necessarily compare too many
shows to ours because you're coming for
an evening right it's like you know
you're going to a two-hour movie and
you're gonna stick it out for the full
two hours so our show rounds about two
hours I would actually like it to be
shorter and we're working on that but um
eight is my maximum and I even find
eight goes long and at that eight
everyone does seven minutes and my last
person will do 10. and we try to keep it
as tight as possible because once again
you know one assume that people are
going to run on the light which is
almost inevitably old face happens
and uh always I'm like oh man this is my
fault
um
and I would say my sweet spot for our
type of format is six so three
intermission game and then three and it
ends up being around 90 minutes or like
just under two hours
but I find eight if you're if you're
having an intermission is pushing it
and I don't suggest doing like
more than 10 when you have that amount
of comics on it because then you're just
like really pulling it out of your
audience
to them unless it's like rapid fire
if their experience isn't hype and
you're not keeping them excited like
toddlers which is pretty much how you
should treat it right like candy candy
shot
no it's not two hours later
um but again it all depends on what you
want but I would definitely suggest like
my dream and my sweet spot which I still
struggle with because sometimes I'll get
a last minute message of a comment
coming from out of town that I love and
they're like yo Eva can I hop on I'm
just like
yes I love you but then in the longest
the show so it'll always I think that'll
always be a battle like in a perfect
world because for monthly I would just
say six uh I think eight for me is the
where we cap it because I've done eight
and I'm like pushing I'm oh my gosh
someone's gonna fall asleep if I don't
keep screaming like an orangutan
[Laughter]
um but I would say six I think six uh at
ten minutes each and also finding a way
to integrate new faces with vets and
also knowing the energy levels of the
comics that you're booking and not
booking too much of the same type of
comics so we really try to find Variety
in the people we book because you have
to appreciate all different types of
Comedy so I had one show where I had a
guy who was a master roaster and the
audience knew he was coming up with that
intention so as a host to set up the
intention of what your audience can
expect can work in your favor a lot
without giving away the other comedian
set of course but to be like this guy is
a master roaster he's amazing he's gonna
come he's gonna rip your souls out so
better get ready and at least they're
not being attacked at that point at
least they're you know they're kind of
ready and they're like this is what he
does this is his type of Art and then I
have another guy who sings with his
guitar and he does guitar comedy and be
like get ready we're all gonna do a sing
along and
as long as you keep people briefed and
you know communication and you keep them
involved and hyped up of what they're
going to be getting they're always going
to be on your side and and treat you
nicely
should be a sound clip that's hilarious
that's a funny comment if we don't put
that one I like it yeah I might even get
use that with my kids
we're still having fun
you want a kid falls and you're like
that didn't hurt that didn't hurt that
didn't work
they're our sponsor
[Laughter]
this podcast is being sponsored by
VeggieTales
oh Veggie Tales
so good get me on Captain Bible soon
[Laughter]
did you have the buttercream gang up
there
the buttercream the buttercream gang
I watched that growing up it was okay
never mind I had I had
um Mr Bible the superhero the superhero
I don't know I just remember buttercream
being like kid it was like yeah it was
like a religious show and kids
troublemakers
no it's Bibleman babe was it called
Bible man or Mr Bible
man his name is
get some merch going yeah yeah Captain
Planet that was it Captain Planet was
good yeah
what is there any is there anything else
that we get to everything that you
wanted to share I know you're you're a
wealth of information do you think
anyone has any questions I think we
covered quite a bit
oh actually I do have something helpful
for people awesome Instagram posting
strategy of reels on tick tock
we need to talk about it okay
so
always caption your comedy videos most
people watch their videos on silent
because they're usually on public
transport or doing something with
someone or standing next to someone and
they don't have their earphones so
always having captions you can use an
app called cap cut to generate those if
you use Premiere Pro they also just
added a feature on Premiere Pro that
will generate automated captions for you
because there was there there's kind of
a rumor going around on the social media
manager community and I've tested it out
myself and what's annoying is that it it
has started working
um there is a rumor going around that
Instagram
prefers that you edit your videos in
their app
because what happens is that if you
if you for example create a video on
Tick Tock and how Tick Tock kind of
automatically saves that video to your
phone it has The Tick Tock watermark in
there and it has all the metadata and
because Instagram is low-key trying to
shut Tick Tock down it'll absorb that
metadata on Instagram and your video
will not get as much reach
so make sure that when you're posting to
those different platforms it's really
important that you post it separately so
don't take a downloaded Tick Tock video
and post it as a real on Instagram
because it won't get pushed as much and
you know and vice versa and they also
want you to use their sounds
um they won't push certain they won't
push certain content that's been edited
on another platform other than theirs so
I tried it out to experiment with it
before talking where I used one app
called inshot to edit a video and then I
used the Instagram in-app to edit a
video what was so annoying is that it
was not the top quality I've ever spent
on a videographer to go viral it's
always the cell phone
clips that you post and it's like two
seconds and it goes viral so it goes
back to that rawness and that
authenticity so you don't need to spend
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
dollars on you know beautiful high
quality footage all the time but I've
found a lot of success in merging both
because it still feels like you found
something or you stumbled upon something
and creating that impression to people
that like oh what is this this is from
someone's phone so they're not just
trying to sell me something which is a
big thing that goes through people's
minds
um but for for social media strategy
that's really important and they want
people posting twice a day on stories
and on their feeds so it's a bit of a
pain but if you're looking to monetize
and where you want to put your effort I
would definitely you know recommend Tick
Tock really only pays 50 to 100 per 1
million views
um Instagram pays anywhere from 1200 to
6 000 per million views and then with
YouTube kind of paying the most around
the range of I think around
6015 depending on of course your Niche
and and your exposure and all that kind
of stuff but consistency is really
important lighting and having a good
camera is super important for
storytelling I've found like your camera
Joel
if you wanted to start a tick tock with
that type of lighting like it would do
probably really well but I've had
friends with really funny videos who
have a lot of Shadows and it's dark and
it kind of looks like my camera and
people aren't as compelled to continue
watching
and crowd work does great crowd crowd
work does great
all the time it's really successful
so oh yeah Sandy asked oh you said this
was very helpful and if you could share
the checklist from your first podcast
and uh your
your presentation from this one as well
yeah so how should people get that
because I want the hot Brothers to reach
out to you I want you to be overwhelmed
like the last time you did the show oh
no I I love I loved that though I like
if you guys have any questions you can
still always message me on my Instagram
it's Eva Alexa comedy and our show
kickback is
kickback.mtl if you guys want to kind of
check out or you know study what we do
or make the things that we do
um I'm always there for that but
definitely in terms of Instagram
don't make your captions too big most
people don't read it you can put writing
on your videos that are really fast and
really engaging and 15 to 30 seconds is
the sweet spot for promo videos
overall and then if you're doing a
comedy clip one minute that kind of
starts off with like why you don't like
something that's kind of what I've I've
learned in my corporate and comedy
research so far
start with so you're saying like the
opening hook of the video is about
something you don't like
well maybe I worded that wrong but for
example some of the videos that perform
the best
are stuff that's are our videos that
start off with a very strong statement
if you're not doing crowd work so it's
like
these are the three Secrets I've learned
to a healthy marriage and it's like for
example it's a comedy clip there's a lot
of people that are like what are the
three seasons
you know or it's like my my my day is
like this or and it's that kind of title
within your set that I've seen in my
research kind of go really far
um and then when you're doing crowd work
putting the title of like
Heckler throws water at Comic using that
example those hooks those quick hooks
that keep people engaged and intrigued
I've seen perform very very very well
kaboom
dropping sauce again I hope I hope this
was helpful
incredibly helpful we appreciate you I
don't know what kind of Greek sauce
there is but you've dropped some
marinara
you did great no this was awesome thank
you so much amazing I'm over here
you guys so wow how did you get JFL your
show became a part of JFL right just
what we're doing we were one of the we
are one of the partners this year for
the JFL showcases so something really
cool in Canada has happened on the
Canadian side is we have this great
great great new talent scout named Neil
bansal and he he has really taken his
job and gone all over Canada during
almost like almost hundreds of of
showcases
um for Comedians and Canadian comedians
to be seen so just off the bat shout out
to that guy but the way I got that is
um I took a chance and I messaged him
and I picked gym just like anyone would
and introduce myself and just show and
and I had heard that he had you know I
had some friends who had you know said
like Montreal Kickback like that's you
know good vouchers I got some good
vouches as well before approaching him
um but he was a really inviting person
and he had wrote and written on his
Instagram saying like you guys want to
send me your tape send me your tape like
there are really good people out there
who are looking
for you and um the basis of what he
explained that they're looking for this
year are people for the festival are
people who have a strong message who are
authentically themselves who have a
strong Viewpoint and and it's really
kind of all out there but what they're
really looking for this year is like who
you are as a comic and what message you
truly want to convey and what that
meaning is and even just kind of getting
that email with that description saying
this is what we're looking for this year
we want people who are genuine we want
people who want to tell their story we
want people who have a strong stance uh
or a strong opinion on something and it
really even caused myself as a comedian
to dig deeper into who I was and what
kind of material that I had to rethink
and if I thought that that was TV ready
so it's really cool to see that
that has kind of taken off and to see a
lot of comics feel even more motivated
and working hard to get ready for their
showcases but it was as simple as I
messaged him and I pitched him and I
sent him our deck and I set up a call
and it was approved and I'm really
excited there's seven showcases in the
city this year which means a lot of
people get to be seen and their
showcases all over Canada and it's just
been it's been really cool to kind of
see how that's grown and it's it's
expanded and there's a lot more people
getting exposure and work as Canadian
Comics so that's how I got I messaged I
pitched it hoped for the best and we got
it and I could die happy now because we
get to give some people some
opportunities to be seen that they maybe
not
might have not had before which was our
why
Circle all back that was our why we
wanted to create
new experiences for comics and set a new
standard for comedy for people to be
seen so annoying we accomplished that is
like
okay I go to White Lotus now
[Laughter]
speaking of Club Med yeah yeah
I think Sandy asked a question about uh
tips for approaching venues what kind of
arrangements have you pitched have you
had a problem with competitors booking
your Venue
or muddying your brand
muddying my brand how dare you the tea
what's the tea Andy who's trying to
muddy your brand girl
first of all first of all when you got a
good brand and you know your ethics and
you know your morals and you have a
strong support system whoever is trying
to muddy your brand just looks Dilly
Dilly dum-dum okay
English
[Laughter]
um however
I I've kind of always had the mentality
because we've definitely had some people
and I think that there's a difference
between people being inspired by your
brand and wanting to create off of
something that you've done because
you've made them believe in yourselves
and they've you know they've integrated
different things and there's a
difference between someone like carbon
copying your your formula right so I
don't think we've ever had anyone fully
carbon copy
um
however I no not really but if that did
happen to be honest all that really all
that really does so for example say
someone tried to create a show called
the
backyard comedy part no that does exist
and those are my friends never mind
they're in L.A the back kick or whatever
back kick Montreal and they have the
same formula and the same everything all
that would really do is it and again it
said if you have a strong brand that you
know you have your audience you know you
have your following all it really does
is make people think of your brand
because they could try to copy it but if
the experience isn't up to par to what
you are providing all it does is make
them look like copycats so I wouldn't
really consider that
um in terms of people trying to to take
a venue from us no not that I knew of
however I did have a recent situation
where
we were working with a venue who really
wanted us to come with them and they
offered us like a sweet deal like super
in our budgets we were we pretty much do
everything out of pocket
um and then because they gave us that
sweet deal and because we hadn't put
down the deposit yet
they came back to us and said well
someone offered us 3 000 so I'm super
sorry you get it it's business
personally
I do not like that I did not like that
at all it was 48 hours before a show and
luckily I had oh yeah it was great I'm
telling you this show I got like one
gray hair right there
um but that's happened to us we've been
double booked but
you know for the most part Montreal is a
really collaborative City and everyone
really helps each other so it's usually
from the venue owners so make sure you
sign a contract
make sure the dates are correct make
sure you know what you're getting how
you're getting it and it is signed
sealed and delivered because once again
I made that mistake we were able to you
know save ourselves last minute and
luckily Micah is one with words and
knows how to maneuver things when my uh
fiery Little Greek personality comes out
and I'm like this is ridiculous business
how could you like I just get emotional
I'm like how could you hurt me and he's
like I've never even met you in real
life and I'm like
whatever
special set of skills if you don't get
this right
[Laughter]
you actually gave her a heart attack but
women right
and I was there with him and I was like
just we just gotta say what we gotta say
to get make sure this you know venue is
intact right now
so you'll basically you'll rent you'll
basically rent the venue and then you
provide all the alcohol and everything
and just take the profits of all that
well we so in Quebec you have to get an
alcohol license
um either work with a venue that already
has an alcohol license
permit we when we're not working with a
bar and we've worked some with with some
great bars like um giggle like sorry
mixed up a festival we're doing I'll
plug that after uh but the Montreal
improv for example is like a great venue
and
when I first decided to go that route I
was really scared actually because we
used to be like a BYOB byow style shows
you come you bring your own liquor you
relax it was part of the charm and um
one of the venues you were working with
wanted to charge us more so I've had a
lot of issues with venues assuming we
make a ton of money and wanting to
charge more but at the same time
they're you know they're thinking that
and then they're also thinking about of
course their own lives and their own
business trying to run a venue so making
sure you have that compassion which
sometimes
In the Heat of the Moment I have not and
I'm like this is business and sometimes
In the Heat of the Moment I have
um finding good people to work with and
making sure that the bar you're working
with is good so when we worked with the
Montreal improv those girls were on it
they were making such delicious
cocktails it went so smoothly and it was
a beautiful show and no one really
seemed to care that it wasn't BYOB in
that moment which was very relieving I
was having a ton of anxiety I was like
no one is gonna want to come to the show
anymore if they can't bring their own
alcohol
you know like my whole team and Micah
were like you're crazy this is not
that's not a pain they come for the
comics they come for the vibe they come
for the experience
um but soon I think we're gonna try to
do the bar thing soon because I would
definitely say if you want to make money
money which is
you know eventually a goal for sure is
is finding a venue that you can apply
for a liquor license so that you can't
because even you know most events comedy
music money is made off the bar so
either you do like a 15 split with the
bar and the club that you're working
with uh and they give you the venue for
free or they give you the venue for free
and they take all of the bar which you
kind of think like oh that's great but
there's a lot of money made in that bar
you know sometimes they're they're
averaging out for a grand a night and
you're selling tickets at 35 but your
cost is 32.
um you gotta you gotta take those you
got to take those things into account as
well where you know say you're doing
BYOB maybe you don't have a bar but you
can have a a Red Bull stand or you know
with some of those other companies like
Coca-Cola or something like that maybe
Sprite wants to sponsor it and you have
mixers
so there's there's ways around it but
you know if someone's trying to meddle
with your brand and like book your Venue
if the venue is being slimy about it
like go on to a new venue because
finding a good venue and good people to
work with at that venue to make you feel
safe and make you feel like your show is
going to be successful is just as
important as finding the right Comics
because we've worked with great people
and not so great people and we've been
burned and exhausted and felt uplifted
and celebrated in so many different
occasions so when you do find those
those people that even if someone is
trying to come in and take it from you
if they're willing to put their foot
down and be like absolutely not we've
partnered with this person already you
know you have a good venue if the venues
turn around and being sleazy about it
and it's a money grab you don't want
that venue because they're not going to
put in and match that energy and that
effort that you're trying to put in to
make sure your show's a success
Kaboom Eva you've done it again
thank you so much let's put some
tzatziki sauce in the hot breakfast it's
just do you pronounce the tea do you say
the tea ever uh I do I don't say ziki oh
I didn't know if I didn't know if it was
like a silent T I don't know
no I didn't yeah it's like a yeah
when you go to your kids after and be
like say this
try that
well what what I'll do Yeah you
mentioned your giggle you're about to
promote something what all do you want
to promote here how tell the hot bread
yeah so what to do um
and talking about the expansion of like
Montreal independent Purdue shows in the
past three years since the kickback
um one of my friends Michelle Forrester
has decided to produce an entire
Festival by herself in Montreal which is
insane
it's my girl Michelle she's that's what
I mean like Montreal is filled with a
lot of comics who have grit and I'm so
proud of it because we don't have a lot
of clubs like the other cities we have
the comedy nest and we have third floor
which is run by Josh Shapiro and he's
amazing he's also a comic who started
this four comics and then we have some
local independent shows after that
because our you know our other comedy
venue accidentally burnt down
yeah
the way you said that yeah very much
Montreal always will understand that
and it wasn't even for our insurance
um so that that that uh so that other
Comedy Club burnt down so other than
that it's
a lot of local Comics producing their
own shows and trying to keep the scene
alive because we're a French city
there's not too too many opportunities
for English comedians so we have to
create it ourselves which is why there's
you know the people here are tough and
they're collaborative and we all work
together and that's why I'm so proud of
her because what she's done is from um
from April 5th to April 8th she's
combined every show in the city
into four days so that montrealers can
see all the shows that happen throughout
the city during the month and catch them
within these four days and then go on to
further support them in the coming
months and the kickback is going to be
closing it out as the as the as the main
closer so I'm super proud of that so if
you guys are in the Montreal area or you
want to learn more you can definitely
check out giggle fest
and my girl Michelle Forrester
very cool
yeah four days 80 artists that's very
cool
we're over 80 artists yeah that's pretty
much our entire scene
[Laughter]
and we'll be sure to uh we'll um we'll
link to uh Kickback and your social
media as well in the show notes of this
and again if anyone ever has any
questions you guys can always message me
on my personal uh on my personal
Instagram Eva Alexa comedy sometimes it
ends up in message requests but I
promise I'll check it
again the same goes for us here on uh
social media you can message us or
um if you join our email list we we send
out notifications of these weekly live
streams we do every Tuesday we have some
great guests coming up as well so
definitely join that email list and
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
start being a part of all the comedy
goodies because we're I mean we share
the same Spirit you know of just helping
helping the underdogs in this comedy
game give them the resources and the
motivation to actually take action and
create their own success in this comedy
game so it's always great to collaborate
with like-minded people like you Eva
well I'm so happy to be back it's so
cool to be back after two years it's
like I miss you man and it's so nice to
meet you Yoshi it's like really cool
addition to the show
appreciate it I mean I feel like we've
been you know I don't know what the
American sauce is but you drop some
Canadian sauce today and we're gonna be
crazy
[Laughter]
I feel like you just dropped some gems
like I mean this is one of those you
know you know we don't we have a lot of
these where like we're helping a lot of
comedians but I'm over here taking just
copious of notes of just like to make my
comedy shows and my produced shows like
better right and I've been doing this
for I've been doing comedy for eight
years probably producing for six and
like you've opened my eyes to stuff that
I hadn't even thought about like
greeting people I love greeting people I
didn't even think about that you know
I'm saying like this is we're all
greeters in the church once
stuff they don't even think about so
like just I love like your background of
marketing of just like taking it back to
the basics of just like how do you make
you know comedy show and experience and
I think sort of that's like that next
level of people just aren't going to
Comedy they want to go to an experience
and you sort of making sure that you
encapsulate all that into your shows is
just it's beautiful to hear but it's
like I love that as comedian oh she is a
sensitive woman don't make her cry
yes Queen yes but like as comedians who
are so like me and Joe you know we geek
out on this stuff like all the time and
we're talk to each other like man this
is we'll talk to each other after the
shows like how was the show was there
any issues like we do feedbacks after
our own shows and like we we geek out to
such a level but to know that like you
have that same
not just level but like experience and
taking that customer experience and that
Fan Experience next level is such a
beautiful thing so thank you for your
time and like just doing this for
comedians you know we've we've watched
comics on here who have started and like
pushed them to like go do the open mic
like just start the open mic go write
that joke write that setup like we'll
help you with it we'll we'll tell you if
it's trash or not because we love doing
that but you gotta go do it you know
what I mean and then tell us how it went
those kinds of things so just the gems
that you drop today are just amazing so
thank you straight up and I I'll say one
last thing I just thought I'm so sorry
but I I've noticed it's kind of helped
us a lot in the community management and
retention of
um keeping a loyal following in people
involve them
like you know your regulars who come in
and we have certain regulars that come
every month or I'll personally message
them just be like what did you think of
that one or I'll come up to them at the
event you're like what do you think of
this venue it just makes them feel
included and like what they have to say
matters more than a survey or even um
the other thing we do is when you're
buying tickets you guys can try this as
well so again we use universe.com
um I made a little question about this
says are are you a new homie or an OG
and then they and then they click it
so I know how many regulars we have to
newcomers every month and we can we can
store that data to then show to other
businesses so that's just one last tip I
forgot that you guys can start
integrating for the long term if it
works that's legit I like that
that's awesome
let's go data data
fire fire fire fire
[Laughter]
I appreciate you guys it was so nice
hanging out with you it actually just
felt like a good hang
ing absolutely well we'll be definitely
doing more together and hot breadth of
verse listening it's go do now you have
the information we'll link Eva's first
episode as well where she gets more into
detail on how to create experiences how
to create your brand around your show
and this was kind of a great sequel so
definitely listen to that one and go out
and get you some
comedy shows going there fam go get me
some smoked meat Rubens and comedy
Bob's in Toronto
beautiful
all right kids everyone have a great day
we love you all
and we'll see y'all next Tuesday for at
the end of every show we dab it out you
gotta dab it out dab
dab hey let's go we'll see you next
Tuesday helper at the verse